hello everyone vasily smyslov is
referred to as one of the two winter
kings the other one being Michael Tao as
he was only world champion for one year
but Smith's Locke could have actually
won the world championship long before
he actually won the world championship
as he was second in that 1948 tournament
after Alexander aliens death that
Mikhail Botvinnik won and well Smith won
the World Championship in 1957 in his
match against Botvinnik but he also won
the previous candidate cycles and the
metric ins Botvinnik was tied so he came
second to both winning the first time
second time he played a match against
him was tied and it was the third a
third time he defeated him but he lost
the rematch and well but when he
regained his title sorry about that I
think I'm getting the flu but this game
was played in 1945 this is young vasily
smyslov he was 25 24 at the time this
game was played and he's playing against
Joseph rudakov ski and this game is well
it's a it's a really nice positional
masterpiece as you can see the quote
above the board I really enjoyed this
quote he plays the same common moves you
and I make only he wins the game says it
makes you about vasily smyslov
and well I like it because it's true as
you'll see in this game so lastly Smith
love is white and he's playing against
the Ukrainian chess master Yoshi for the
Koski I couldn't find the photo of the
guy unfortunately so we have a four by
Smith Slav and c5 the Sicilian defense
Knight to f3 d6 d4 seek after 74 knife
captors and e4 and knife to f6
we have Knight to c3 and now d6 the
Sherman again variation Bishop to e2
Bishop to e7 missile castles rudakov ski
castles Bishop to e3 Knight to c6 and we
have f4 Queen to c7 and the Queen to e1
now there's a an exchange of knights
knife character son before Bishop
captures and d4 and hero the cops keep
lady five and he was somewhat criticized
for this move as it doesn't really
accomplish much for black
it's well it makes d5 in the future
really hard to play and maybe a b6
followed baby should be someone was
better here but okay he decided 45 we
have Bishop back to e3 and now Bishop to
e6 seems like a normal development but
missile plays f5 we have Bishop to c4
Bishop captures on c4 Queen captures in
c4 and Bishop to g5 and what's miss
loves idea with this Bishop to g5 move
well he's he's not allowing blacks to
push d5 and you know as long as you
don't allow like to push d5 in the
Sicilian
you're doing okay is white so rook to
ft8 by rudakov scheme and we have Bishop
captures on f6 s missile decides to give
up the bishop as we have Bishop captures
and f6 and Knight goes to d5 and now
this Knight is occupying a white square
on d5 there is no peace Rudovsky has
death can ever disturb this knight on d5
this is a beautiful piece and well he
actually is kind of offering this pawn
and c2 but the one cannot be taken if
for example Queen captures and c2 then
not rook the c1 immediately to threaten
night to see summon but first rook to f2
has to be played you do have to defend
the b2 point you don't want to give up
too much points just to grab a rook so
after pointing to c5 and Rock the c1
Queen well not to be 6 obviously I have
to look to see one maybe Queen to b4 and
now Knight to c7 and well white is
better here he's grabbing the exchange
and this is this is very nice for white
so after this Knight to d5 idea know the
cost he didn't capture the pawn of
course he played at Bishop to d8 now we
have c3 now I'm not allowing to capture
a pawn because now the bishop is
covering c7 and we have a B 5 B 3
kicking out the Queen Queen the c5 would
check King to h1 and rook the c8 now
having pressure to the c3 square and
Smith off plays rook to f3 a very nice
rook lift as its defending the c3 pawn
allows the knight to move and also it
will be helpful maybe this pawn will be
pushed to f6
maybe rope the g3 will be played maybe
root 2 H 3 we'll see we have King to h8
Berger dekosky and here's missile
immediately pushes f6 and can can black
capture this pawn well it would be
fairly dangerous if well I mean now the
pawn has to be captured but can g6 be
played for example if g6 then rook to h3
and well but cannot defend this there is
there is the terrible threat of rook
captures on h7 followed by Queen to h4
check and only way for black to even try
to defend this would be to play
something like g5
but then Queen d1 and it's unstoppable
Queen to h5 followed by Queen to h7 so
after this f6 move
Rudovsky capture the pawn G captures on
f6 we have Queen to h4 now by Smith's
love and pressure to this f6 pawn but
also with the idea of group 2 H 3 n 2
into h7 checkmate solar up to g8 now
with rook to h3 r up to g7 is ready
source missile captures and Knight
captures and f6 now threatening
checkmate on h7 we have worked a g7
and now a beautiful move boys missile
rook to g3 and here the Koski captured
Bishop captures and f6 but what's the
idea if rather costly played for example
Queen to f2 and this is beautiful as it
seems
well it seems that missile can't
sacrifice the Queen with rook captures
on g7 and threatened rook captures on h7
would checkmate because after Queen
captures on h4 now the queen is
defending this h7 square but what
Smithville's idea actually was to play
Queen captures on 87 and now there is no
move for the black king
rook has the capture of Queen and now
rook to g8 with checkmate
so very nice idea base missile after
this rook to g3
so although the Koski saw this he played
the Bishop captures and f6 we have Queen
captures on f6 now this rock is pinned
Queen captures and g7 is threatened Roxy
the g8 defending and our rook 8 d1 and
black is without a move here rook
captures and
only six is threatened ideas like h4 h5
h6 are coming this is pretty much
unstoppable so I wrote the Koski tries
one more idea if he plays d5 butts me
Slav immediately punishes this with rook
captures and g7 we have rook after Sun
g7 and our rook captures on d5 and well
like it's without a move the queen is
attacked and whatever the wherever the
Queen goes white simply plays rook to
the 8th with Czech salt Queen has the
Queen has to go to last rank because
it's checkmate and simply rook to d8 and
this wins the Queen rook g8 Queen checks
rock g7 and grabbing for example a pond
completely winning for white so after
this rook to d5 move mr. joseffer lock
off ski resigned the game and well the
twenty or twenty year old 24 year old
vasily smyslov played this beautiful
game it was played in the 1945 USSR
championship and a special definitely do
that well actually he shared 10th place
but he did play this interesting game so
yeah I do hope you enjoyed this game by
by the winter king vasily smyslov and i
would like to thank one tinker and man
orange and mishra for a contribution to
my channel thank a lot i really
appreciated
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon